in the last video we tried to draw a two
propyl
propyl heptane
and we did our best attempt at drawing
it but it was pointed out that this
wouldn't even be called two 2-propyl
heptane to begin with so you actually
should never see something called
2-propyl heptane and let me show you
what i'm talking about so when you see
something like this you might
immediately say and well the way we drew
it was actually correct it just wouldn't
be called 2-propyl heptane so you say
heptane so that is a seven carbon alkane
no double bond so one
two three four five six seven and then
on the second carbon so you have one two
three four five six seven we have a
propyl group propyl that is three
carbons so on the second carbon
we have a propyl group that's three
carbons so that is one
two
three and so the way we drew it was just
like this and so someone gave you
2-propyl heptane this would be what you
would draw but you wouldn't call this
2-propyl heptane because remember if
you're given the molecule you look for
the longest chain and the longest chain
here is not the heptane chain it is not
one two three it is not this thing in
magenta in this kind of mauve color it's
this chain where you start over here
if you start over here
one two three four five six seven eight
nine you actually get a longer chain so
this would actually be the backbone of
this molecule
right over there
that right over there would be the
backbone and so you would number it and
you start numbering closest to the group
that's attached so one two three four
five six seven
eight
nine so you have nine carbons in your
backbone so we're dealing with non-ain
we're dealing with non-name
and you have a methyl group one carbon
attached to the fourth carbon of our
main backbone so this is going to be 4
4
methyl
for
methyl this is our methyl group right
here
for
methyl
for methylnonine
so it was brought up i think the the
username is minoc2 and they correctly
corrected me that there would never be
such a thing as 2-propyl heptane i just
made that up if someone were to were to
kind of label this molecule they would
call it 4-methylnane and ask you to draw
it but either way both of these would
point you to the right direction
this would just be the incorrect name
for it because you'd be looking at if
someone gave you this molecule you named
it this way that would be incorrect so i
apologize for this this is for methyl
nonine if you do heptane you're not
finding the longest chain